so the Kanye West anti-Semitism
anti-jewish comments just will not stop
we have another short interview to look
at and again the I want to really
explain to you all the reason I'm
content I don't care about Kanye West I
don't care about him as an artist and I
don't care about him as part of the
cultural milieu what concerns me about
Kanye West is that it is the
prototypical example of a guy who is
saying insane things about Jews and it's
just not taken as seriously in social
media and elsewhere
as it would be if it was some other
individual a white person for example
attacking a different group and this is
the soft indifference to anti-Semitism
that I have spoken about before West is
unhinged let's look at some clips he was
interviewed by Chris Cuomo now on news
nation which is the it's a new channel
of some kind
asked about the anti-semitic comments
themselves and here's what he had to say
couldn't it also be that you have said
things that offend the community
guidelines like anti-semitic comments
and things that are seen as insensitive
uh and potentially threatening to
communities that we try to protect
[Music]
well I don't like the term anti-semitic
yeah a lot of anti-semites don't it's
been a term that's allowed
people specifically in my industry to
get away
to get away with murder sometimes
literally wow literal murder is
happening because of the word
anti-Semitism you know I get away with
robbing and doing bad people people a
lot of robbing happens because of the
word anti-Semitism this is this is sick
I always say I got screwed on a deal is
it would that become to surprise to you
if I said hey a music exec screwed
someone on a deal does that sound kind
of like normal commonplace to you so for
me it doesn't have anything to do with
being anti-Semitic
it does if you're Kanye because his
argument is that the Jews are screwing
him I
you believe that all record producers
are Jewish or you know it's when you
talk about Jewish people specifically he
is targeting them that creates a problem
anti-semitic but I don't believe in that
term one thing is he doesn't believe in
it guys imagine if someone said after
after throwing around the n-word and
they were like that's that's insanely
racist then they go I don't believe in
the term racist oh all right well I
guess it's fine black people all situ I
classify as Jew also so I actually can't
be an anti-semit so so the term yeah
Kanye can't be anti-semitic because he
also is Jew as he likes to say I'm not
gonna do the full explanation now about
uh this entire black Israelite 12 lost
tribes thing I've already done it a
bunch of times before but that movement
in and of itself is quite a racist
movement
um here's another segment from this just
completely delusional interview in which
Kanye says he's been texting with Kid
Rock which doesn't come as a huge
surprise to me I must say it's actually
something Kid Rock uh just gave me a
text about that go to places where
you're celebrated not where you're just
tolerated you know I bring a lot he's
his Kanye's upset that his aunties he
has very in a very he wants to be given
some kind of prize for calling out the
Jews essentially he's not being
celebrated for his anti-Semitism of uh
I bring a lot of
attention to these platforms to
Instagram and to Twitter and they Silo
you they they Shadow ban you everyone
knows that was Shadow bad or Instagram
yeah exactly and what's Wild is he's
even using the rhetoric of these right
Wingers the right Wingers always tell me
David you've Shadow banned me on your
platform and they get it from prominent
right Wingers and Republicans who have
been talking about Shadow bands for a
while uh and now Kanye is using it this
guy's disgusting it's not getting the
reaction that I believe it deserves and
now potentially Kanye is going to buy
himself social media platform parlor
which we talked about on yesterday's
bonus show